Up to this point, we've been working with opaque materials. Where light hits the
surface, and bounces off. For a number of reasons, transparent objects are more
challenging. First, light refracts, and so changes its direction when it hits a
transparent surface. For example, here light comes from the surface of the
pencil, travels through water, and hits the glass. The glass causes the light to
go in a different direction. Such the different light rays reach our eyes and
cause the pencil to look bent. This change in direction can also affect the
distribution of light on a surface. This crystal ball acts similarly to a lens,
focusing the light and creating various bright spots below it. In computer
graphics, we call these bright spots caustics. The color and the intensity of
the light can be filtered by the transparent object. The farther a ray of light
travels through an object, the more light that can be absorbed. Even thin
filters can change the color of the light. All of these effects can be simulated
or at least approximated in a convincing way. Refraction where the light changes
direction is expensive to do correctly. I'll be discussing it further in later
lessons. It's also possible to computer the amount of light absorbed due to
traveling through an object, though this can be costly. In the following
lessons, I'm going to focus on absorption of light by thin transparent surfaces,
such as these eyeglass filters. To simplify further still, I'll be talking about
only the effect of such filters on objects visible through them. In other words,
I won't be talking about how light passes through such a filter, reaches another
surface, and then travels to the eye. I'll only be talking about light that
travels from the object through the filter. This all sounds like a lot of
simplification, but you can get wonderful effects from just this form of
filtering alone. For example, this fantastic demo made by Alexander Roddick
shows how transparency can be used to effect. There are other cool effects going
on here, such as the God rays of light. But transparency is what really makes
this demo shine. It's 1 of my favorite Web GL programs. .